y para hablar de economía me acompaña
nuestra periodista especializada daniela
blandón daniela buenas noches para
ustedes y comenzamos hablando de brasil
porque petrobras tiene un nuevo
presidente este es el cuarto que ha
tenido en dos años y medio hola maria
clara buenas noches pues viene el último
presidente de la petrolera que se llama
josé mauro coelho salió del cargo a
principios de este mes después de apenas
dos meses en este cargo el nuevo siguió
aprobado por la junta directiva es cayó
para desde andrade un comunicador social
que trabajó en el en el ministerio de
economía y sin experiencia en el sector
esta es una decisión que los sindicatos
petroleros prometieron llevar a la
justicia porque aseguran que no cumple
con los requisitos de ley para asumir el
cargo ahora los tres predecesores de
padres de andrade habían sido derogados
por el presidente hay bolsonaro por el
mismo motivo y es un desencuentro que
hay en torno a los precios de los
combustibles ya que la popularidad del
mandatario ha caído drásticamente en
medio de un panorama de altísima
inflación y él ha buscado que petrobras
cambie su política de precios
combustibles que hoy están anclados como
en muchos otros países al comportamiento
del precio internacional del petróleo
pero eso no ha sido fácil para ya ir
bolsonaro ya que petrobras a pesar de
que tiene mayoría estatal también cotiza
en bolsa y tiene alrededor de 700 mil
accionistas minoritarios y ahora
hablemos de una cifra porque 25 millones
de empleos se perdieron en la pandemia
según la uce de lo dijo maría clara el
jefe de la división para américa latina
y el caribe de esta que es la
organización para la cooperación y el
desarrollo económicos también también
conocido como el país el club de países
ricos y jose antonio ardavín él aseguró
que además de los empleos perdidos
durante la crisis sanitaria 25 millones
también cerraron 3 millones de empresas
en su mayoría micros que representan el
99 por ciento del aparato es empresarial
y generan el 60 por ciento del empleo la
cepal por su parte estima que la pobreza
regional este año subirá al 33 por
ciento de los habitantes de la región y
que la pobreza extrema va a llegar al
14,5 y ahora hablemos de un desencuentro
porque washington y el kremlin tienen
versiones distintas sobre el
incumplimiento de pagos de rusia bueno
lo cierto es que hoy vencía el periodo
de gracia de 30 días que tenía rusia
para pagar unos 100 millones de dólares
de intereses de dos bonos
internacionales según la casa blanca
hasta la primera versión también
respaldada por la agencia de
calificación moody's el pago no llegó y
se configuró el primer impago en más de
un ciclo pero la clave está en la
interpretación legal que se le dé al
asunto y es el kremlin asegura que tiene
el dinero pero lo tiene en rublos y que
ya desembolsó este mismo en rublos pero
el pago fue bloqueado ya que rusia se
está alejando cada vez más del sistema
financiero global la explicación la dio
el portavoz del kremlin
nuestras reservas están bloqueadas
ilegalmente y todos los intentos de
usarla también serán ilegales de hecho
equivaldrían a un robo total estas
afirmaciones sobre el incumplimiento en
la economía rusa carecen de toda
legalidad rusia realizó los pagos de
bonos requeridos en moneda con
vencimiento en mayo y el hecho de que
hayan sido bloqueados y no llegarán a
los destinatarios no es nuestro problema
en este caso no hay razón para llamar a
esta situación un incumplimiento y
argelia descubrió su mayor yacimiento de
gas en 20 años una buena noticia no
solamente para argelia sino para europa
porque sonatrach es la empresa estatal
de energía de este país africano y dijo
haber encontrado vastas reservas del
hidrocarburo en el campo llamado fácil
mail y agregó que de inmediato puso en
marcha un programa de desarrollo para
confirmar los volúmenes estimados y
lograr una producción de alrededor de 10
millones de metros cúbicos por día a
partir de noviembre de este año para que
se hagan una idea eso quiere decir que
su producción podría subir cerca de un
10 por ciento respecto del actual
este anuncio es importante primero
porque argelia depende en un 20% de los
hidrocarburos y segundo porque es un
proveedor clave para italia para españa
y también para otros países del sur de
europa y justamente ahora que están
tratando de buscar sustitutos al gas
ruso una buena noticia como usted lo
dice daniela y cuáles son los
indicadores del día las acciones en wall
street terminaron ligeramente a la baja
después de las fuertes ganancias de la
semana pasada las bolsas europeas
entretanto cerraron mixtas después de
que el g7 se comprometiera a apretar más
las finanzas de rusia con nuevas
sanciones sobre el petróleo que a
propósito subió más de dos dólares en la
jornada y en américa latina la bolsa de
sao paulo subió más del 2% impulsada por
este nuevo presidente de petrobras del
que hablaba y ahora sí cuál es la cifra
del día 24.000 millones de dólares esa
es la fortuna estimada por bloomberg de
leonardo del vecchio él es el dueño del
imperio que posee firmas de lentes como
rey ban y oakley quien murió este lunes
a los 87 años esta fortuna era
considerada la segunda más alta después
de giovanni ferrero que es el dueño de
nutella las acciones de la empresa
estilo luxótica cayeron más del 1 por
ciento en milán después de conocerse
esta noticia gracias daniela por toda la
información económica y nosotros
seguimos con más aquí en directo américa